[موسيقى]
في الثامن يونيو اتذكر انه بعد ان تناولنا
الغداء كنا باعتبارنا اطفال نلهو حيث كان
مسموح لنا باللعب داخل ساحه المعبد بالقرب
من الملجا وفجاه سمعنا صراخ الجنود ورجال
يطلبون من الفرار والابتعاد عن المعبد
بسرعه لانهم تلقوا معلومات تفيد بانه
سيكون عرضه للقصف لذلك تعيين علينا ان
نهرب باسرع ما يمكن لقد بدات في العدو مع
اخوتي صوب الطريق الرئيسي وبمجرد بلوغنا
الطريق السريع الاول كان بامكاننا رؤيه
طائره بصدد تحليق وسماعه هذه المحركاتها
الذي يصم الاذان لقد كانت على مسافه قريبه
من رؤوسنا رفعت راسي الى السماء ورايت بام
عيني كيف ان اربع علب سوداء كانت بصدد
الوقوع منها ثم بدات اصوات الانفجارات
فجاه اثر ذلك تنير تلتهم كل شيء من حولي
حتى انها وصلت الى ثيابي والتهامتها وبدات
حريق جسدي
[موسيقى]
اول ما رايت كان ذراعي يسرا والسنه النار
عليها فاستخدمت يدي اليمنى لمحاوله
اطفائها ولذلك احترقت هذه اليمنى وما زلت
حتى اليوم احمل اثار ذلك في تلك اللحظه
اكتشفت ان الجزء العلوي من جسدي اصابته
نيران ولكن المعجزه ان رجلي بقيتها
سليمتين ولم تصل هما الالسنه لذلك كنت
قادره على العدو حتى رايت شقيق واقاربي
وبعض الجنود هناك فاستمرارنا في الجاري ثم
الجري ثم الجري لا نلوى على شيء استغرق
ذلك فتره ما شعرته اثرها انني لم اقعد
قادره على استمرار في العدو فتوقفت واصبحت
اصرخ من الحراره حاول احد الجنود مساعدتي
اعطاني الماء لاشرب ثم سكب الماء على جسدي
ولم يكن يعرف ان ذلك سيزيد من السوء
الواضح لذلك فان التصاق النبال بالماء جعل
وضعي اسوا بكثير ولذلك فقدت الوعي بسبب
الالم الفظيع ولم اعد اعي اي شيء من حوله